У Польщі наприкінці травня традиційно починається збір овочів та фруктів.
Проте, як і торік, фермери можуть втратити частину врожаю, якщо не приїде достатньо
сезонних працівників з-за кордону, зокрема українських заробітчан.
Принаймні так стверджують представники рекрутингових компаній.
Портали з пошуку роботи рясніють ласими пропозиціями.
Усі кажуть про те, що погода дуже хороша. Це означає, що буде добрий врожай.
Зараз Польща дуже потребує заробітчан. А перш за все - фермери.
У червні починаються полуниці. У серпні - малина.
Потрібні люди, які допоможуть зібрати врожай.
У минулі роки до Польщі на піку врожайного сезону приїздили
близько 100 тисяч сезонних працівників, переважно з України.
На додачу до польових робіт, кажуть рекрутери, влітку потрібні
десятки тисяч людей у сфері послуг та готельному господарстві:
Вже виходимо з пандемії. Польща відкрила ресторани, готельний бізнес.
У цих сферах також працювало багато заробітчан.
Нагадаємо, навесні 2020-го внаслідок оголошених локдаунів
десятки тисяч трудових мігрантів були змушені повернутися в Україну,
адже потреба у робочій силі різко зменшилася.
Безвізовий в'їзд до Шенгену призупинили.
Нині ж Польща - одна з небагатьох країн ЄС, які вже фактично відновили дію "безвізу".
Для перетину кордону від сезонних працівників вимагається або робоча віза,
або біометричний паспорт із запрошенням на роботу.
Плюс негативний тест на коронавірус, обов'язково зроблений у Польщі.
Пункти тестування є прямо на кордоні.
Більше того, українців за бажання навіть вакцинуватимуть від "ковіду"
прямо на польському кордоні.
Щеплення робитимуть тим, хто їде до Польщі працювати, вчитися
або на тривале перебування.
Причому препарат Johnson&Johnson, який тут використовують,
вимагає лише одного щеплення.
У Центрі східноєвропейських досліджень у Варшаві підтверджують,
що нині у Польщі великий попит на українських працівників:
В цю пору року існує гостра потреба у сезонних працівниках,
перш за все у сільському господарстві.
Тут задіяні не лише українці, у більшості це все-таки працівники-поляки.
Але, як ви знаєте, у Польщі існують демографічні проблеми.
І багато поляків поїхали на заробітки до Західної Європи, зокрема Великобританії та Німеччини.
Тому зараз дуже потрібні українські трудові мігранти.
Конкретних даних про те, скільки саме персоналу бракує та скільки українців
вже приїхали на сезонні роботи, наразі не мають ані роботодавці,
ані польський уряд, ані економічні експерти:
На жаль, ми не маємо таких оцінок. Я не бачив жодних цифр
і від польського міністра розвитку. Але, як це не парадоксально,
сільське господарство не є основним сектором польської економіки,
де працюють українські мігранти. Їх найбільше у сфері послуг та промисловості.
Отже, сільське господарство є важливим, але не найголовнішим.
Асоціація компаній з міжнародного працевлаштування України прогнозує,
що загалом, зокрема, на сезонні польові роботи за кордон цього року
поїде близько пів мільйона українців - це на третину менше,
ніж в часи до  пандемії.
Коронавірус все ще залишається важливим стримуючим фактором
для трудової міграції в Європі, кажуть економісти. І все ж, Польща,
однією з перших відкривши свої кордони для іноземних працівників,
робить усе, аби левова частка українських заробітчан приїхала влітку
саме сюди, а не, наприклад, до Чехії чи Німеччини.
Звісно, що такі країни, як Чехія, Угорщина, Словаччина, країни Балтії
і раніше не дуже багато брали українців на роботу, тому що кількість населення
там суттєво відрізняється від кількості населення Польщі.
І звісно, що ця країна - маю на увазі саме Польщу - буде залишатися
і у майбутньому найбільшим ринком для працевлаштування українських трудових мігрантів.
Загалом, за нашими оцінками, в Польщі навіть на зараз знаходиться
біля одного мільйона українців.
Тим часом Варшава відкрито зацікавлена не лише у сезонних працівниках з-за кордону,
а й у залученні персоналу з вищою освітою, зокрема спеціалістів з галузі IT та медиків.
Представниця польського уряду Івона Міхалек нещодавно заявила про підготовку
додаткових спрощень та стимулів для іноземних фахівців.
Серед іншого - у вигляді отримання іноземцями допомоги на дітей та іпотечних позик.
В уряді підкреслюють, що роботодавці дуже позитивно оцінюють працівників з України та Білорусі.
Такі позитивні сигнали з Польщі на адресу потенційних трудових мігрантів з України
конкурують зі здебільшого голослівними закликами української влади
на чолі з президентом Зеленським залишатися працювати вдома.
При цьому стимулів з боку української держави, на думку експертів,
поки недостатньо, аби стримати відтік фахівців з України.